I'm page I'm a grad
in computer science and I worked with a
team of eight on a game called snap all
of us were course six majors in computer
science we created a game called snap
which the our client who is from the Red
Cross he presented us with this class
this game in class the game works where
you both come up with words two players
come up with words and whenever you say
the same word you snap and you get a
point so our task was to create digital
version of this game both to make the
game more engaging and also to help them
collect data on what words people were
submitting because it's sort of a free
association game and helps them get a
sense of what people think about a
complex topic
so for snap we actually had a concrete
game that the client gave us and we knew
exactly what project would be working on
snap is also a little bit different in
that it's a much more technical game
because you don't have we're not coming
up with sprites we're not coming up with
a story it's quite bare bones in terms
of interface and so we had a much more
standard coding project for our game but
at the same time there were game design
aspects to what we had to do we still
have to think about how to go beyond
what we played in class and go port over
the game to a digital version that would
still be engaging and didn't rely too
much on the human interaction the
face-to-face interaction so at first we
actually thought that our game would be
much more restrictive because we thought
that the clients had a lot of existing
ideas about how the game should be
played and what works well for getting
good feedback out of people as we went
on we were pleasantly surprised to find
out that we actually had a lot more
creative freedom than we thought and
really they just wanted something that
resembled the original game and
accomplished what we needed which was to
get people to give words and say what
they were thinking so that was really
nice for us to to be able to really
think of what we wanted to at the same
time though the client was interested in
using the game much earlier than we
expected the goal for all the projects
is that they remain open and available
for people to see over the next month we
have actually been running the game in
the past couple weeks and that has also
required some effort on our part to do
exactly what the client needs for their
specific runs in the past week
so traditionally this course does not
allow people to use networking because
it tends to be very buggy it tends to be
something that if it doesn't work simply
makes the whole game fall over flat and
we decided to violate this rule very
early on the rules are all suggestions
after all and we did we were confident
in our ability to do this partly because
we had a lot of experience with
networking with distributed systems I
actually work in distributed systems and
we also works experienced with the
technologies that we were using which
definitely helped i think that the
learning curve for those technologies
was a little bit more than we could have
done in these eight weeks
so this this course is nominally about
creating video games but in reality as
the instructors admitted it's about
project management and i think that the
course does a really good job of
teaching your project management by
example by forcing you to actually do it
and I think that's why it's structured
as for games as opposed to one big game
which is what you might expect and I
think that that was really useful for us
to learn project management game
development was a nice side benefit but
I don't think we learned a lot of game
design I think we just tried it and
mostly we were learning how do you
manage a project how do you manage a
software project games are a little bit
different in that the goal is fun and
not so much coming from a client the
last project notwithstanding mostly
games are about you want to create
something fun I think the biggest
challenge for us in snap was getting
people engaged getting our team engaged
in the project there's a lot of other
classes that people are taking and this
is not necessarily the highest priority
on everybody's list and that was
something that you really have to work
around you really have to find ways to
get people engaged in the topic and get
people to contribute where they can in
the number of hours that they have
available so i don't know how completely
successfully we were at getting people
to contribute as many hours as we need
it but definitely part of it was making
sure that tasks were very clear so that
not everybody was thinking about the
whole game was but instead could think
about their specific tasks and what they
need to do on their part and that was
part of what the project management was
was making sure that people have the
information they need to do the tasks
that they need to get done without
thinking about the whole project